mon premier jeu de l'arrivée en france
c'était ici en ayant des voeux fin
j'étais avec mon copain américain de
l'époque et on a eu rendez vous avec le
propriétaire d'un appartement bon ton
que japonaise normalement on doit
arriver sans qu'à 15 minutes avant deux
rendez-vous c'était froid on était
dehors et puis la france 1 ils étaient
en retard de 15 à 30 minutes on était
tous crimes ce par quoi et quelle misère
donc c'était quand même un bel heures
départ leurs parts au patch dette était
enfin miniscule ça fait treize mètres
carrés un truc comme ça et on arrive la
porte canapé-lit date havre kitchen est
c'est tout après oui enfin il ya la
fenêtre qu'il a fait comme ça et on a pu
bois la toile f1 je chie bugnon temps
pétillon donc j'ai attendu l'avis
étudions aussi
donc j'ai pas content du tout de suite
avoir pété accès à tout ce qui est
pression c'est normal
nero image quand même con on a eu cinq
j'ai eu front j'ai fait au japon c'était
quelque chose comme hervé eu un peu
comme marie-antoinette si ici ses deux
premiers endroits que j'ai balader on
allie vont en france le fameux seul
c'était quand même romatique il ya des
cupr comme ça qui va l'aide aussi et on
arrive on ici je me suis dit mais tient
le tf elle n'est pas autant de jolies
pas toutes les photos qu'on voit c'est
de toi fl allumé avec le lumière donc ça
dont les images comme quoi que en fait
est fait et on or il ya beaucoup de
japonais qui et kiala symptômes comme ça
s'appelle barbès syndrom qui a eu une
sorte de dépression à cause de décalage
les images après le japon et la france
veut tu vas tu avais fait le même c'est
doré ont barré au monde est clair comme
ça en fait des images c'est plutôt comme
ça
doré
après c'est un peu exagéré j'ai jamais
vu à
un artiste avec des moustaches et dv les
ondes but c'était de être styliste
donc moi j'ai décidé d'aller à
l'université américaine qui était basé à
l'époque à côté de l'école militaire et
mon idée premiers aidés c'était de faire
deux ans à new york pendant deux ans à
paris et ensuite de deux ans à new york
et finalement tard il m'a pris beaucoup
donc ça fait 18 ans que je vis en france
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup d'écrits attaque qui a
été houspillé par le kimono
mais il n'y avait jamais le moment le
kimono même a été présentée en france
donc je me suis dit mais tiens moi je
travaille dans la mode
et puis moi je suis déjà à paris et
taris et les capitales de la mode
donc c'est ça qu'il faut fait que je
suis venu en france pour étudier la
morde occidentaux et qui n'a mangé chez
un porc 8 ans né à la source c'est ma
rêve qui est concrétisée